THEY WELCOMED HIS REEMERGENCE
INTO THAT BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
READ IT HAS BANNED A PAGED USED
BY TRUMP SUPPORTERS FOR FAILING
TO ABIDE BY THE COMPANIES
CONTENT POLICY.
REDDIT SAYS THE COMMUNITY HAS
HOSTED AND PROMOTED REAL BRAKING
CONTENT, ANTAGONIZE OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN THE GROUP’S
LEADERS HAVE FAILED TO MEET
BASIC EXPECTATIONS.
THE PAGE SAYS VIEWS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM ARE ALLOWED
BUT ALMOST WORK WITHIN THE
POLICIES.
TWITCH, A VIDEO STREAMING
SERVICE OWNED BY AMAZON FOUNDER
JEFF BEZOS, HAS TEMPORARILY
BANNED PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ACCOUNT
FOR HATEFUL CONDUCT.
EVERY BROADCAST OF TRUMP’S 2015
CAMPAIGN LAUNCH AND COMMENTS
FROM HIS RECENT ALSO RALLY WERE
FLAYED BY THE COMPANY.
WHICH SAYS THE CONTENT HAS BEEN